[Musik]
daraus hat der unfall gehabt hatte war
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
heute startet experiment ich glaube ich
nenne es allen experimenten morath zum
gare kabel was sagst du zum experiment
der schaft volles coole wortspiel ich
glaube immer wenn ich jetzt in zukunft
im experiment mache nämlich zum
experiment ich möchte heute einen angel
food cache machen und zwar ist es einen
kuchen aus den usa der aus eiweiß
besteht ist deswegen kein gesunder
kuchen also nichts für dich fürs
fitnessstudio sondern einen kuchen der
wirklich komplett das eiweiß besteht ein
richtig heller kuchen da man eben auf
geld verzichtet und sehr locker und ich
kenne übrigens umkämpft naja mit der
gestern ich habe das gestern schon
ausprobiert und der stoff von
eingefallen wirkung dagegen schon
probiert das richtig da war zerstört
kann das bild muss zeigen ja so sah er
aus oder aus ich habe auch einen großen
fehler gemacht und zwar habe ich in den
amerikanischen rezepten steht immer drin
cream auftrat und übersetzt heißt
weinstein und ich habe außer den
weinstand backpulver genommen das heißt
der kuchen ist im ofen quasi explodiert
und dann in sich zusammengefallen und
halbprofis jetzt ohne cream oft haben
aber die gäste übrigens nichts
weggeschmissen größte gegessen sondern
lenkern bot die band richtig dicke und
hat deswegen ich probiere es heute ich
hoffe es gelingt mir jetzt mit diesem
rezept ohne weinstein backpulver ich
lass einfach mein stein weg weil es gibt
es bei uns einfach nicht als einzelnes
lebensmittel überall zu kaufen
das dient nämlich zur stabilität des
eiweißes aber wir probieren sie es
einfach ohne wenn's klappt klappt wendet
dann halt nicht aber ich hab das video
hoch mega salehs experiment ich zeige
euch mal die zutaten dafür benötige ich
280 gramm eiweiß eine prise salz 150
gramm zucker etwas bittermandel aroma
wandel extract 100 gramm puderzucker und
80 gramm mehl
jetzt gibt jetzt zuerst das eiweiß in
eine rührschüssel unauffällig
verklickert ich habe es jetzt auch
abgemessen ein eiweiß von der größe m
wiegt 35 gramm also sind es acht stück
falls ja aber warum das wichtig ist weil
manchmal hat man ja weiß übrig das ist
ja echt ne coole eiweiß resteverwertung
wir nehmen jetzt mal anders klappt dann
ist eine coole eiweiß resteverwertung
und dann hat man auf das eiweiß in der
schüssel im kühlschrank
weißt du nicht mehr wie viele das waren
und ein eiweiß der größe m hat 35 gramm
das heißt wenn ich dann mal ganz viele
rezepte mit eigelb machen und habe weiß
im kühlschrank oder im gefrierfach übrig
kann ich einfach abwägen da kann es auch
einfrieren
das ist ja das coole du kannst eiweiß
und eigelb getrennt voneinander im
kühlschrank wirklich mehrere tage
aufbewahren und auch einfrieren
das heißt ihr müsst wirklich nie was
wegschmeißen und so was könnt ihr doch
mal nutzen zur resteverwertung ok und
jetzt eiweiß mit der prise salz steif
schlagen wenn er ein steifes com jetzt
hier der zucker langsam dazu und dann
ruhig so lange weiter bis die eismasse
also das pc einfach schön steifes und
glänzt
[Musik]
jetzt ist der schnee perfekt und ich
habe jetzt hier ein sieb und jetzt ist
wirklich wichtig butter zucker und mehl
7 3 fach 7 ich muss jetzt nur einmal
machen denn ich habe ein dreifachsieg
hier in meinem sieg drin
ich gebe dir also die zutaten rein denn
so entstehen keine klumpen puderzucker
ich habe ja auch ein deckel drunter
deswegen bleibt die arbeitstische sauber
jetzt braucht ihr die küchenmaschine
nicht mehr
den rest erledigt jetzt der teig aber
ich gebe jetzt hier das vanille extrakt
doch so wahrscheinlich auch der punkt
warum du morath gesagt hat der kuchen
schmeckt so gut denn ich am panel
extrakt drin und bittermandel aroma
nicht einfach extrem gut hier wirklich
nur ein zwei oder drei tropfen das
nämlich sehr konzentriert und jetzt in
zwei bis drei fraktionen die mail
puderzucker mischung einfach unterheben
[Musik]
alles vorsichtig untergehoben und jetzt
nehme ich hier meine backform in amerika
gibt es auch eine spezielle backform
extra für angel food kate wahrscheinlich
ähnlich wie bei uns für ein kuchen eine
google hochform
ich mache jetzt aber so ich habe jetzt
hier ein lochblech meine dauer bank
folie und einfach einen bug ringen wir
können auch eine springform neben
bildern springform habt und jetzt
einfach auf 22 zentimeter durchmesser
einstellen
und hier in der mitte habe ich jetzt
einfach ein glas was gleich mit gebacken
wird
das heißt das ist dann der us cent der
center des buches soll ich jetzt
verschlagen das ist hier im innern das
innere des kuchens also da bleibt
einfach weg und es bleibt ein loch in
der mitte und steht für dich dass jetzt
ein
ich hoffe so sehr dass es jetzt klappt
[Musik]
obst okay ich halte mich nicht mehr
selber meiner angaben
also 22 habe eben noch gedacht 'oh ich
machen über das bisserl weniger okay der
kopf hat es richtig gemeint aber die
hände haben doch nicht so funktioniert
kennst du das buch wünsche ans universum
da gibt es anscheinend so ein buch ich
hab selber noch nie gelesen aber man
kann wünsche ans universum schicken und
dann passiert es auch wenn man den
wunsch richtig ausspricht
jetzt hoffe ich dass ich den wunsch
richtig aussprechen
liebes universum bitte lasst die
sensation
den besten blick auf der welt werden
kate fand das jetzt in den backofen bei
160 grad die backzeit finde ich gleich
noch raus ich stelle jetzt erst mal 20
minuten ein gucken es gleich an
aber ich denke er braucht 25 bis 30 auf
jeden fall nicht zu kurz backen damit er
beim backen später nicht zusammenfällt
glaubt mir ich spreche aus erfahrung
untere einschub leisten
das klappt schon wenn ich mache ich den
löffel das wird raus
[Musik]
und so gegenstände die mit viel in
kontakt kamen
die wasche ich immer gerne mit es habe
dazu einfach hier so wie sie es sich
essenz dann riecht es reinigt also
einfach ein kleiner schluck wein geben
so macht es auch in der spülmaschine
dann rechts mit und alles ist so frisch
[Musik]
mit 20,5 nachgestellt ich mache den ofen
nicht auf aber ich sehe die oberfläche
ist es leicht braun aber ich glaube noch
nicht dass er durch ist und ich will
jetzt nicht riskieren dass war
herunterfällt
ich lasse mir noch mal fünf minuten dann
habe ich 25 stäbchen probe macht man
auch immer das vielleicht auch so ein
bug basic stäbchen probe macht man immer
nach etwa zwei dritteln der zeit klar
wenn man ursprünglich nicht weiß wie
lang die zeit ist sind die zwei schritte
angabe ist die auswahl riesig
aber wenn ich jetzt keine ahnung eine
stunde lang den kuchen im ofen habe die
backzeit eine stunde ist dürfte
frühestens wirklich nach einer
dreiviertelstunde den ofen aufmachen
oder nach zwei dritteln also nach 40
minuten
ich lass mal noch ich bin halt auch
nicht dass dazu dunkel wird aber der
rand dafür ruhig ihnen ist er ja
hoffentlich dann schön weiß okay ich
warte die drei minuten noch und dann
machen wir also nach insgesamt 25
minuten man stäbchen probe aber momentan
wieder gut aus
danke universum
[Musik]
sieht gut aus
wackelt ist wattestäbchen probe da ist
schon noch ein bisschen zu feucht in
also diesmal nach meinem gefühl ich
mache es aber zehn minuten drauf wer
minuten hatte es schon noch schon noch
nach ihnen und ich will nicht dass er
zusammenfällt
also noch mal zehn minuten womit habe
ich das verdient
ich war jetzt gleich man nicht meinem
instinkt trauen sollen ich hab ihn zu
früh eingestochen
er ist abgefallen war so schön und so
perfekt und er stößt jetzt hier hat ihn
kaputt gemacht aber jetzt ist ja durch
das schmerzt richtig weil es war alles
so perfekt und dann jetzt jetzt wollte
ich ihn aus dem ofen jetzt hole ich den
kuchen aus dem ofen heraus ich meine
nicht gleich naja murat hat gestern auch
schon den zusammengefallenen gegessen
und es hat ihm geschmeckt und fällt mir
auch nicht auf guck mal wie hoch der
wahl der wahl ungelogen noch x 4 cm höhe
und jetzt ist einfach zusammen gefallen
weil ich den backofen zu früh geöffnet
habe also laut originalrezept gehört
daher auch cream of qatar ein und die
original backform ist so eine alu
backform und die stellen die dann auf
dem kopf zum abkühlen
ich mache es jetzt auch aber ich kann
nicht versichern was jetzt passiert aber
ich glaube diese scream auf tat hat es
bewegt tatsächlich doch etwas mehr als
ich dachte ich nehme jetzt schon mal
dann geht's
der wird jetzt raus fallen und wird
plumps machen ich sehe schon
und normalerweise muss da jetzt so
abkühlen damit die damit die höhe des
kuchens einfach nach unten also
schwerkraft sich nach unten zieht und
dann behälter eben auch seine schöne
höhe
ich lasse ihn jetzt einfach mal abkühlen
und dann gucken wir einfach was daraus
geworden ist
ich kam zu einer erkenntnis und ich
werde sie gleich mit euch teilen
das mikrofon anschlag wurde die
küstenwacht wird die krise schon lange
nicht mehr aller machen das ist mir
schon gedacht so viel romantik am
arbeitsplatz so sammer also wie der
titel hier heute ist experimentell april
ist oder ist das team gefahren also ich
wollte diesen angeles gekauft wird und
ich kam zu der erkenntnis dass du
wirklich weinstein brauchst also krieg
oft hast du schon jetzt damit nein das
jetzt ausreden damit die eismasse schön
stabil bleibt und die amis die haben
recht du musst es in seiner blöden
aluminium backform backen denn am
aluminium klettert der kuchen hoch kann
drin abkühlen umgedreht also kopfüber
und dann tut man den daraus aber ganz
ehrlich bei uns in deutschland oder in
europa back einer mine aluminium das ist
einfach mega gesundheit ist es ist ja
nicht unser verdacht demenz auszulösen
soll das ist das erste
macht man nicht mehr so er ist jetzt
auch gern vergessen ganz ich denke nicht
dass du mich echt gerufen damit ich
diesen fladen hier probieren ich habe
ich habe meine zuschauern versprochen
dass ich unter dem joch dass ich das
video hat sich bis morgen soll ja
versprochen dass ich das video hochladen
egal was passiert und ich habe jetzt
gestern das hier gebacken
da dachte ich okay kommt aber egal wer
wo sie hinkommen es liegt an der
guglhupf form und da hatte ich noch
backpulver drin weinstein backpulver war
so ein test der kuchen ging ja so auf
und er stand zusammen geschafft dann
okay
dann kam dieses kunstwerk das war von
heute da habe ich gedacht okay ich hab
den backofen zu früh geöffnet
ich habe es gerade eben noch mal
probiert und es liegt wirklich daran du
brauchst dieses blöde cream auftrat war
damit der kuchen tv behält aber weil
schwarz dem geschmack des wahrscheinlich
eher kein abbruch nach was an der kugel
schmecken wo ich sagt die weißenseer
coni ganze stelle ich habe ihn gestern
schon gegessen weil da habe ich schon
dienst aber nicht einfach was soll der
schrecken der schmeckt nach eiweiß und
zucker und schlecker muss ich sagen
ehrlich der schmidt kam
der lässt sich wunderbar schon einen und
aber und das ist das schlechteste kuchen
vom aussehen anders gemacht dass ich
habe niemals irgendjemand können wir
können sie nur rennen aber hier passt so
ganz frisch hat dass ich nicht schlecht
an gelten
entschuldigung aber ich habe schon so
viele tolle rezepte gemacht wenn ich
hab's mit kürbis immer wieder habe er
ist schmeckt demnächst und jetzt bei so
einem glas schmeckt nämlich begreifen
wieder schmecken würde windows
funktioniert jetzt ist das erste video
ist so wie sie frauen hat das das
nächste mal mache ich mit birken zucker
und verkaufs einfach als eiweiß kochen
dieses low carb jetzt nicht aber dann
trug sich das war ein experiment ein
experiment und schmeckt parlament und
ich finde ganz ehrlich ich finde wir
können öfters experimente machen
ausprobieren gucken ob es klappt mal
gucken wie die quote wird also in der
aluminium buck vom kind so ich benutzen
ja ich m nach dem kuchen habt ihr also
wir vergessen ich probiere das nochmal
ich probiere es normal
es kann ja sein die mit papieren ich hab
dir nicht sogar na ja nun mal was
anderes
dem trat mit ins team
der schmeckt echt nicht schlecht dritten
ausgabe der erzählung war okay macht's
gut macht's besser geschmeckt
ich bin selbst vom nächsten spektrum hin
macht den kuchen okay ich sage dass ich
habe das noch nie gesagt
bitte mach den kuchen nicht nach
durchmacht demnach aber nicht so ok
[Musik]